[موسيقى]
مواقيت الصلاه خمس اثنين نهاري واثنين
ليلي وواحده فاصله مواقيت صلاه الظهر
والعصر نهاريه والعشاء والفجر ليليه
والمغرب فاصله والمواقيت النهاريه
والفاصله تعتمد على قرص الشمس والليليه
تعتمد على شفق والنهار يولد من رحم الليل
بالانفجار ولهذا سمي فجرا اقم الصلاه
لدلوك الشمس الى غسق الليل وقران الفجر ان
قران الفجر كان مشهودا والفجر فجرين فجر
صادق وهو الذي يعقبه ضوء وفاجر كاذب وهو
الذي يعقبه ظلمه فهو ليس صادقا في ظهوره
لانه لا يعقبه ضوء والعرب القدماء يسمون
الكاذب بذنب السرحان لانه دقيق في اعلاه
ومتسع في اسفله او الذئب فانست بالذئب اذ
عوى صوت انسان فكدت اطير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وما ظهور التلويث البيئي والضوء الناتج من
الثوره الصناعيه ظهرت اشكاليات حول مواقيت
الصلاه الليليه العشاء والفجر والفجر هو
الاشكال فقديما كان العلماء يقولون ان وقت
صلاه الفجر يحين اذا كان انحطاط قرص الشمس
عن الافق الاقرب ياتي 19 او 18 درجه
والابحاث الاانيه الدقيقه الحديثه وهي
الاصح تقول ان وقت صلاه الفجر يحين اذا
كان انحطاط قرص الشمس عن الافق الاقرب يا
17 او 16 درجه والخلاف بينهم اختلاف تنوع
ليس اختلاف تضاد مهما العقول تباينت فيما
ترى تبقى القلوب بودها دوما تفي هب ان
رايك غير رايي يا اخي ما شان ود بيننا
ان يختفي
[موسيقى]